this is a production of Cornell
University so today I'm gonna focus on
one particular problem that we're
working on that has nothing to do with
seaweeds its plants which is useful I
think for this audience um and it's
talking about an isotropic growth and
what you'll see in particular is that
we're focusing on the hypocotyl as a
system to study this but obviously
there's lots of places within a plant
where an isotropy will occur so
extending these principles beyond that
will be something that we're interested
in doing next so let's see if I can
figure out how to use the pointers this
I'm just going to use this okay so our
general question in the lab is trying to
ask how shapes get grown in Walled
organisms and I say plants and algae
because I don't really look at East or
bacterial so I'm looking at
multicellular Walled organisms and it
presents a really interesting physical
challenge so you have a wall that's
surrounding each cell but also for the
most part connecting cells to each other
and connecting tissues to each other and
so physically speaking when you want to
have coordinated growth that gives you a
shape or a pattern you need to have
coordination of that physical process of
growth and in general as you'll see I
consider that as something that's really
mediated by the cell wall so here's an
example of some of the systems that we
look at and some of the organisms we'll
use but as I mentioned we're really
going to focus on maybe it just doesn't
have a battery that's okay I can dance
around we're gonna focus on the high
picado today so so when you want to
understand how shapes are grown oh thank
you whether you're talking about a cell
shape or the shape of the tissue or a
whole organ you need to do different
things so first of all you need to be
able to quantify shape so we did quite a
bit of differential geometry to look at
how shapes change in time and how you
can quantitatively describe them you're
going to talk about how you actually
think that change in shape comes about
and to do that we look at some physical
principles and also some material
science so the cell wall is material and
then we're going to look at how the cell
wall biochemistry relates to those
material changes and how the cell
biology underlies that change in the
material
and finally of course I'm a
developmental biologist at heart so I'm
really interested in how the signals
from the genetic program get translated
into this physical change in shape so
today what I'm going to focus on when I
start learning how to use the computer
is mostly these two here so what kind of
saw well changes are happening during an
isotropic growth and what we think maybe
some of the regulatory mechanisms for
that might be but there'll be a little
bit of material science at the end so
this is my diagram of the cell wall just
don't freak out so it's an incredibly
stylized really simplified description
of what we think a cell wall looks like
and pointing out that of course as some
people in the audience will know we
don't really know what the cell wall
looks like so we know there are
cellulose fibers in there we know that
that's embedded somehow within a PEC
tenacious matrix and pectin is their
chemical I'm going to talk most about
but there's also you know cross links
hemicelluloses that can happen in
between fibers and we're starting to
learn a little bit more about the
architecture of the wall but it's an
incredibly difficult structural thing to
work with and so a lot of the things
that I'm gonna say about the mechanics
of the cell wall we're taking a lot of
assumptions into the structure as well
and hopefully we'll learn more about the
structure and link that to the mechanics
over time but with a big grain of salt
we think that the cell wall has these
strong rigid fibers whose orientation
can affect the material properties but
you also have the matrix within which
they're embedded which is what I'll
focus on today so our questions about
the mechanical cell wall is how does the
wall change during growth in shape
formation what component of the wall or
components might be important for cell
growth or shape growth and and how they
actually mediate that and actually also
how we can test the properties of the
wall in vivo and so as Adrian mentioned
they've been involved a lot in using
atomic force microscopy as a way to test
the material properties of the cell wall
and I'll go into that a little bit for
you so today what I'm going to do is
focus on the high picado we're going to
look at a role for pectin methylation
in hypo cuddling and isotropy then we're
gonna look at how maybe modulating an
isotropy could have some interesting
functional functional consequences for a
plant so instead of just saying oh
that's a cool microscopy picture why it
might actually be useful to change your
ant isotropy and then at the very end if
we have time I'll do a little bit of
what we're looking at to actually link
the back chemistry of pectin to the
material properties of gels and how we
can translate that back into a plant so
it's probably a little bit super phorus
for this audience but the hypocotyl is
an important organ it's located between
the root meristem and the shoot meristem
in a lot of dicotyledons plants and
what's going to happen is you need this
extreme anisotropic elongation of this
organ to get the apex out of the soil so
you can start getting photosynthetic
capacity happening and producing leaves
and so yes so this happens from the
point of germination you start getting
this massive and isotropic elongation of
this organ and so that's the study
system we're going to work with today
and obviously it's important for the
early success of plants and as crops you
know the first thing that happens in
their life is germination but after that
you've got to get out of the soil so one
of the ways that we watch this happening
is by simulating a continuous reach for
the surface so we grow things we grow
seedlings in the dark these are rabid
OPS's high picados growing in the dark
and visualized using infrared light and
so what we can do is essentially make it
so they never think they get out and
they're just gonna continue this
elongation until they run out of
resources and so what we can do from
that is we can monitor length over time
in really precise ways so we can get
quantitative descriptions of this
elongation as it happens so they start
doing some fun things at the end which
I'm not going to talk about but I like
these Wiggles as well they're dancing so
as far as anisotropic growth goes that
elongation more in one direction than
another we
but the direction for an isotropy but
also a magnitude so in this case it's
pretty easy the direction of the high
picado is pretty much always up so it's
not that it goes up and then it starts
getting fatter you're just it's a
continual direction for the an isotropy
but the magnitude actually changes in
time so what I'm going to show you in
the next slide is that you start off
relatively slow but then it gets faster
and that magnitude has to do with
differential regulation of the
elongation growth and the width growth
of cells which I'll also show you some
data for so if we take our movies and we
quantify the length of the hypocotyl
over time and you've probably seen this
before because this is a well-known
phenomenon you end up with what some
people call a sigmoidal growth curve so
it's sort of slow increase in length at
the beginning and then you get a
transition around 24 hours after
germination to this more rapid
elongation and so that's what we're sort
of tunneling down into one of the things
is what's controlling this transition to
the rapid elongation but also underlying
that is what's making sure that most of
the growth is going into length and not
a lot into width which would be a waste
of energy if your job is to get you up
out of the soil okay so this really is a
change in growth magnitude and isotropy
magnitude so what we did is we looked at
the cellular level as well so we wanted
to know what cells were doing at this
point so this has been done once before
and it was with scanning electron
microscopy and they really just looked
at cell length over time but if you
think about it so lengths and widths
that ratio is what's important also for
an isotropy and if you only ever measure
length you may be losing some
information by not looking at width so
what's happening in this colorful slide
is mostly the elongation of the
hypocotyl happens by cell elongation
there's not a lot of division at least
in epidermis and so that allows us to
track or pseudo track cells by position
so you have the 1 to 17 cells per file
and because these are growing in the
dark as soon as you take them out to
image them they stop growing so we're
pseudo time series by sampling at each
time and so then what we can do is we
can say well this is
one two three four and we can calculate
individual growth curbs and individual
growth rates by position that along that
file does that make sense so the first
thing that you'll see is if you just
look at the top of this there's that
transition to fast elongation and what
you may know already which is known in
the literature is that all the cell's
don't start elongating at the same time
instead you get this what we call an AK
Repetto wave of the elongation so the
cells at the base start along hitting
before the cells up near the top and
that happens in a wave you can see it
really nicely here these are still small
cells in length here whereas these are
elongating and that wave of elongation
actually travels up the length of the
hypercar so you have what looks like a
pretty simple behavior slow growth fast
growth for the whole organ but it's
underlaid by this interesting wave of
elongation that moves from the base to
the top and that allows us to look at
elongating and non elongating cells or
fast and slowly elongating cells at the
same time so what's over here is sort of
the first real measurements of widths
that are happening at the same time and
what you can see is that the change in
width doesn't show that back Repetto
waves and the cells are expanding in
width very slowly so this is a full
order of magnitude different scale so
you're really you're expanding and width
really slowly compared to length and
you're not having that position
dependent control of where that growth
in width is happening so you don't get
that sharp transition to a fast growth
either so this really is indicating that
the growth and width and the growth and
length are somehow being independently
regulated that's what we might say okay
this is the cellular level mechanism by
which that organ level behavior is
coming up but what we wanted to ask was
how that transition to rapid growth was
achieved and what that really means is
what's happening at the base where those
cells are elongated versus the top where
they haven't started quickly elongating
yet and then also how that direction
going more up than in width is actually
happening and so there's obvious roles
here for cellulose orientation which
ever
we'll know about and I'm gonna hope to
add to that a little bit today with a
pectin story so let's start with this
how do you get that transition in rapid
growth so if we go back to this data
we're really interested in that sharp
transition where things start getting
really fast and it's because the cells
at the base are starting to elongate
much more quickly and that allows us to
ask this question about the cell wall
chemistry between the fast and slowly
elongating cells at one point in time
and so because of some work that we've
done previously in Filat axis looking at
pectin chemistry we knew that there was
some link between pectin and where you
would get a new organ forming at a shoot
apex in Arabidopsis and so we wanted to
ask whether or not we could see similar
changes impacting chemistry here along
the high picado due to that expansion
gradient so I'm going to introduce Homa
collector on an to you this will be the
most biochemical this slide gets so
there are people in this room whose tree
is better than mine so I apologize but
basically in Rabbid OPS's the major cell
wall pectin is homo collector on ends so
it's a really simple chain of galactic
acid and when it comes out into the cell
wall its esterified so these little
orange balls are meant to be those
methyl ester groups and what will happen
once you're sort of in the cell wall is
that you can be selectively Dias
terrified by pac-man or pectin methyl
esters this then takes off some of these
methyl groups and then what can happen
there is that you can then cross link
with calcium so this is this really
canonical calcium chelation that will
happen in pectin gels not it's analogous
to what happens in alginate whether the
the chemistry is different but you get
this calcium cross-linking get rigidify
patient of a gel so what I've got in
this table is sort of what we predict
the mechanical character of gels made of
these different types of pectin should
be so when you can't calcium
cross-linked you should be generally
more soft as a material as soon as you
can calcium cross-linked you should be
more rigid that makes sense it's like
making Jam you're setting the jam and we
some antibodies that actually let us
look at the presence of these different
epitopes within the cell wall which is
what we're gonna look at next but we can
make some hypotheses about what we think
might be happening with respect to
growth so when the pectin is more
methylated it should be more soft maybe
even more fluid growth should be easier
in that case the cell wall material
should deform more versus when you have
calcium cross-linking things are a
little bit tougher and it might be
harder for the cell wall to actually
extend now the reason that this one in
the center says it's possibly rigid is
because there are more complicated
dynamics that can happen you can have
demethylated pectin degraded by poly
Galacta renée's and so if you're
chopping your pectin up that's
definitely going to be a softer gel then
if it's just you know sitting there
without calcium cross-linking because
you're actually chopping up the backbone
so just because you have PMA activity
doesn't mean you're always going to be
more rigid it depends on presence of
peleg electron is is and also presence
of calcium ions okay let's take a look
at what these antibodies look like in
that elongating hi picado I think oh yes
I have to mention that we also have some
proteins that we can use called pectin
methyl esters inhibitors that basically
stop this enzyme from D s terrifying the
pectin so we predict that they should
keep the pectin in a more fluid state
whereas if you over expressed p.m. YZ
you might end up with pectin in a more
rigid state and then we'll come back to
that in a minute
okay so these are transverse sections of
high picados at 24 hours post
germination when we know the basal cells
are actively quickly elongating and
these top cells are slowly long eating
and so LM xx this is the methylated
pectin hopefully what you can see here
is that there's more signal down at the
base than there is at the top although
the quantifications with these things
can be very difficult so I caution you
but up in the slow growing cells we
definitely have more labeling with the
too rigid or possibly rigid antibodies
for Hg so what that means if you look
down at the base is that you should have
more of the fluid pectin and up at the
top you should have more of the rigid
pectin and so the idea is that the cells
at the base are
able to elongate or part of the reason
they're able to along it is because
you're you're keeping that pectin in a
more fluid state so it's getting
delivered and it's not getting converted
into the more rigid rigid rigidity it
rigid able pectin okay
so if that's true can we actually test
that and this is where the atomic force
microscopy comes in so hopefully I'll
start this movie while I talk so this is
an image of an AFM experiment going on
and what you have is a very small tip
here which is actually going to do tiny
indentations along the surface of the
hypocotyl
so we're limited to looking at the
epidermis right now but we can poke and
essentially what you're doing is asking
if I apply a force for example to the
surface of this table if I apply the
same force to the table how much does it
indent the table versus how much that
force would indent my arm and so by
looking at the force and deformation
that you get at different areas along a
high peccato or between two different
materials like me in the table you can
learn something about the material
properties and if you do this quickly
you're going to be looking at the
elasticity of the cell wall so if we do
that at the base of the hypocotyl
during at four hours so when everybody's
going really slowly this is the
transition to rapid growth at the base
and this is when things are really
kicking it what we can see is that this
number we get called the indentation
modulus is going down in time and so an
indentation modulus just relates the
force to the deformation that you get
and so the higher it is the more force
you need to apply to get the same
deformation and the lower it is the less
force so it implies that the material is
getting more elastic over time which
correlates really well with this
increasing growth okay
that makes sense this is nice and
consistent well what happens if we alter
pectin chemistry so based on our
predictions of what soft and what's
allowing growth to happen if we mess
with the home of lecture on an structure
we mess with its mechanics maybe we'll
also change growth and so we're going to
go back to those two enzymes the PME and
the PME I the inhibitor to try and
change the kind of pectin that's in the
cell wall and see what happens to growth
so as a
reminder for you the PME is catalyzing
the removal of methyl groups so this
should allow pectin if there's not a lot
of poly collector on a as present to
calcium cross-linked and become more
rigid but if you have inducible p.m. II
I that should block p.m. ease activity
and leave you more in this fluid state
and so we've done this with alcohol
inducible p.m. e and P Mei lines but
there are only one p.m. E and 1 p.m. e I
and there's about you know sixty to
seventy of each family in a rabbit ops
Asst so there are a lot of these genes
out there but in this particular case
we're just taking one p.m. e 1p me I and
asking what happens if we induce ibly
over express them to the growth of the
hyper kado so luckily i don't know this
is just what happened so what you can
see here in grey is that normal
non-transgenic but treated with the
inducer which in this case is ethanol we
get the slow growth and then the
transition to rapid growth and what
happens when you overexpress the PME is
that you kind of just always have slow
growth and you never get that rapid
transition probably and we've done the
biochemistry to look at this because
you're only having conversion of all the
pectin into that calcium cross-linked
form or pretty much all of it so
everything's really rigid everything is
slowing down and the opposite is true
when you have the PME i which keeps all
the pectin that comes out in that fluid
state and you really you're growing much
more quickly earlier and you sort of
have a more flat fast growth throughout
the length throughout the growth of that
mikado so it has the predicted changes
we would expect on an organ level but
also a cell level so because of the way
the induction works we don't see the
phenotype right away you see it sort of
at 40 48 hours we can see a little bit
better so this is cell length they look
the same at the time of induction but 24
hours later you can see that the wave of
elongation is happening so this is the
cell index from the base to the top the
PME eye cells are a lot longer at the
base versus the PME cells which are
pretty short all the way along so we're
having that change in the organ and the
change in the cells predictive based on
the chemistry so that's pretty nice i
will note that we still don't know why
changing pectin
kissa tea actually has that effect on
growth so that's something we're working
on what is the actual physical thing
that's happening in this cell wall that
says because your gel is rigid you can
grow less so maybe next time essentially
what happens is that PME blocks this
rapid growth phase and Pei is promoting
it so what we would want to see is that
we can see the change in mechanics that
we also expect to happen and so luckily
that also works out with the AFM so now
I'm showing you the AFM data in a map
first of all so each point along this is
a single indentation experiment so you
can get some spatial information as well
so when you have PME expression things
are generally more rigid this is that
indentation modulus so the higher this
is the more rigid the cell walls are and
here we have P Mei and things are a lot
softer more elastic I'll note that these
experiments are done in plasma lytic
conditions because this cell wall is
quite thin compared to the turgor
pressure inside when you're doing these
indentation experiments depending on how
you do them oftentimes you need to
reduce the turgor pressure so you're not
just measuring pressure when you're
poking on a cell and so I'll show you a
graph now so it's a little bit more
quantitative but you can see that the
indentation modulus of the
non-transgenic is almost halfway between
when you induce PME and when you induce
PMI so they're having that mechanical
effect and the effect on growth we'd
expect okay this all sounds pretty good
but now I want to ask this question
about how the direction and and isotropy
is achieved and what you might have
noticed if I go back one is one of the
things you get is some spatial
information and you might notice that
these transverse walls appear to be more
rigid in the non-transgenic than these
are long gating walls and a really easy
way to explain that is because these
walls are just thinner so if you push on
something that's thinner it will feel
softer regardless of if the material is
different but we know we've actually
done some measurements on cell wall
thickness here and we know that the
walls are maintaining the same type of
thickness so we think it's actually due
to this chemical difference in the
pectin
so those walls appear to be more rigid
the slow walls that might control width
expansion are more rigid than the
elongating axial loss so let's
investigate that a little bit more when
we ask how that direction and and
isotropy is achieved so we looked at 24
hours which is close to what you saw
before we're looking at 48 with the
induction but this is 24 and already we
can see these walls are more rigid than
the fast alarm giving axial walls but
even at 4 hours post termination when
everything's growing really slowly we
can still see that there's a difference
already in these transverse versus axial
walls so this is something that's set up
pretty early and it's coincident with
the fact that that growth is always an
isotropic you're always elongating more
in length than you are in width it's
just that it gets faster past 24 hours
so we've done some quantification of
this as well which is maybe a little bit
more believable so at 4 hours we can see
that there is a difference between the
transverse and axial wall as the
transverse walls are more stiff you see
everything gets a bit softer by 24 hours
which is what it showed you before but
you can still see that this maintenance
of the ratio between slow and fast
growing walls is maintained and so you
may also have noticed that pectin could
be involved in this as well because in
the PM E&P mei / expresses which we'll
look at again we've actually abolished
that difference and so now we're looking
at transverse sections sorry
longitudinal sections of high picados
and we're looking at high picados cells
near the base at four hours and then
we're gonna look at 24 but remember even
at 4 hours we could see this difference
in the elasticity of the cell walls and
so what I have marked here with red
asterisks are endosperm sections so and
then this is epidermal files marked in
green is kind of hard to orient yourself
so what you can hopefully see is that in
the epidermal file these two more rigid
pectin markers have higher signal on the
transverse walls and they tend to have
on the axial walls and the opposite is
true for the softer pectin marker
20 where you have more signal in these
trends on the axial walls and less on
the transverse again these are really
tricky to do quantitatively but it dives
pretty well with the mechanical
measurements that we can make and we can
look at this at 24 hours as well and see
once these cells are starting to
elongate we're again seeing a little bit
more of the rigid markers on these
transverse walls here more of the soft
pectin on the elongating walls you can
see it gets a little bit more
complicated there is some rigid pectin
on that elongated wall as well so it's
not as simple as saying well if you have
this pectin you will grow and if you
have this pectin you won't but it's
really difficult right now to work out
that quantitative relationship so we're
working on it but it's pretty difficult
especially with these techniques okay so
you have difference in the elasticity
between slow and fast growing walls that
same difference is mirrored between the
slow and fast growing regions of that
accra petal wave and we can correlate
really nicely the chemistry of the
pectin with the elasticity of the walls
and growth so when we go back to those
PME and PME i overexpress so this is the
same image that you saw before but now
we're focusing on the fact that the
ratio between the transverse and axial
walls has actually disappeared so the
non-transgenic treated with ethanol
shows the rate difference but the PME
it's everything is rigid there's no
difference anymore and the PAI
everything is soft there's no difference
anymore and you can see that before I
showed you the length of the cells but
now I'm actually showing you the length
versus the width and you can see the PME
I cells are way more an isotropic so the
ratio of length to width is more and the
PME cells are less am isotropic so
you're affecting the an isotropy as well
as the elongation rate so one question
that came up in the literature based on
this observation is whether or not
elastic asymmetry is actually enough on
its own to drive an isotropic growth in
the night mikado so if you just pretend
that cellulose and isotropy doesn't
exist if you just have
differ than you do axial walls is that
enough to give you an isotropic growth
so we've done a little bit of
computational modeling with Henrik
Johnson's group at the Saints Barre lab
in Cambridge to ask this question and
again all the assumptions that get into
your model change perhaps what your
outcomes will be but it looks like in
our hands if you take this we're doing
this with a finite element method model
so we can prescribe material properties
to the different cell walls we can say
you should be more elastic or less
elastic than these other Direction walls
and ask then if we simulate growth what
happens and it's using a modified
Lockhart model so what happens we
measured about a two-fold difference
between the transverse and axial walls
and elasticity if we add that in the
thing just balloons so that twofold
difference in elasticity is not enough
and maybe you know we're not getting the
true measurement who knows but if you
pump it up to a hundred full difference
it is enough to give you an isotropy so
what you're looking at for the colors
here are how anisotropic this strain or
growth is and in this case the direction
of the an isotropy is shown here with
the white lines so with no nothing just
everybody's all the same you end up
growing more in width but if you do this
hundred fold difference in elasticity
between these walls and these walls then
you can get some anisotropic growth but
we think that's probably pretty
unrealistic and it's pretty unrealistic
to believe that pectin would be the only
thing than controlling anisotropy
especially since we know that cellulose
is important so what we did next is we
simulated some an isotropy from
cellulose and in the hypocotyl it's not
straightforward in the way that it is in
paul green's original work in nutella
so in those instances you have cellulose
fibers wrapping around the girth of the
cell and that is meant to restrict
expansion and width but if you can allow
those fibers to slip a part you can
facilitate growth in length and that's
this canonical way of controlling
anisotropy in some organs that tends to
be true and some species that tends to
be true or remember we're looking at the
epidermis here
in a rabbit obsess the epidermis doesn't
show really strong alignment of
cellulose what we know now is that the
cortex shows pretty strong alignment so
what we've done in these simulations is
not say that the epidermis itself has to
have that material cellulose and
isotropy we're just providing it either
from the interface of these cells or
actually what you'll see next is from
inside layers of tissue so no matter
where that information comes from what
happens is that you get anisotropic
growth when you have cellulose and
isotropy that's good but if you add on
this twofold difference in wall
elasticity you actually get more in it's
a triplet growth it's stronger
anisotropy and it's faster so you can
sort of see that here this is with the
twofold elastic asymmetry added this is
before growth and after growth you can
see the cylinders a little bit longer
and the degree of anisotropy is a little
bit higher and it's even more profound
if you simulate internal and isotropy
but again these numbers are kind of just
made-up but again you see that
additional thing and so what we think is
that this pectin asymmetry in the in the
epidermis it's not the only thing
controlling and isotropy but it's
helping and isotropy to happen it's
helping that grouse to happen a little
bit faster and it's making sure that
you're those walls are elongated a
little bit faster than these transverse
walls and that could be a really
important developmental advantage okay
so obviously we want to know what
regulates that ant isotropy and I don't
have an answer for you today but we're
looking at some cytoskeletal dynamics
and delivery and ENSO cytosis and
exercise ptosis balance but also some of
these other modifying enzymes where do
they get delivered where they activated
but we might also be interested in
whether or not the regulation of an
isotropy can actually be functional so
why would you want to get out of the
ground faster I mean it seems to make a
lot of sense but let's see okay so let's
go to the second point which is looking
at modulation of anisotropy and growth
plasticity so this little guy has to be
long get out of the soil it makes sense
you might want to do that
right because then you can
photosynthesize sooner you establish
yourself maybe you beat some neighbors
out of you shade competition you get out
faster or you establish yourself
everything's better for you but there's
a lot of environmental variability that
they're dealing with so what kind of
soil do they have to go through does the
compaction of the soil change whether
you'd want to go thin and fast or fat
and slow um how much carbon and other
nutrients are available to you and and
maybe you want to respond to that in a
different way and so there's all these
complicating factors that go into saying
well maybe being faster isn't always
better and so what we noticed in the lab
is that if you grow a rabbit up this is
very very natural if you grow rabbit off
this on plates with sucrose their
anisotropy is actually different so what
it looks like in this video is that
these are shorter they're slower and
they're shorter and that's kind of you
would think well maybe that's a bad idea
but when we calculated their volume and
their volumetric growth what we saw is
that it was identical so they're growing
the same amount
they're just Patricia nning that
photography English I don't have an
excuse but they're giving less growth in
length and a little bit more in width so
the volume maintains but they're
Patricia partitioning I just stop saying
that where it is different in lengths
and widths so when you have sucrose
you're less anisotropic okay so I can
tell you that this is not based on
ethylene which is a possibility so
you'll know that the triple response
involves you getting really short and
really fat but if we do this in the ACS
ethylene synthesis octuple mutant you
still get this response so it's not
dependent on there being ethylene
present which is that good control and
it also happens no matter what kind of
sugar you throw on it so we're looking
at the aunt isotropy index so this will
be the ratio of length to width and you
can see normally they're way longer than
they are wide when you put them on
sucrose that drops because they're
getting fatter and it happens if you
have sucrose glucose dextrose fructose
galactose trealose
so it doesn't appear to be specific to
any one carbon source and the other
interesting thing is that if you chop
off the cotyledons we're turning dodging
a source of carbon you mimic the low
sucrose condition and if you add little
grains of sand back on top to be a
weight that doesn't rescue it so it's
not as if it's because they're lighter
they grow faster we think it really is
something to do with the availability of
carbon and you can rescue that caught a
lead and remove all non sucrose mimic by
actually adding sucrose back in lanolin
to the tip so it looks like it's that
carbon source that's really important
now what we don't know is how this is
being sensed so but there is something
there that's changing this anisotropic
ratio so we can see this at a cellular
level as well so this is the zero
percent sucrose you can see that
increase in lengths of these this is
just looking at one cell in the base
over time you're seeing less growth in
length and also widths remember you
don't really see much of a wave in width
in the normal condition but you're
seeing a little bit of a wave now here
when you have this sucrose so you're all
of a sudden the width birth rate is
getting regulated perhaps by that same
accra pedal wave so there's an
interesting shift there are there cell
wall changes and maybe they're related
to pectin that's probably why I'm here
so again these can be really different
difficult to quantitate so we're doing
our best but this is immuno for the LM
20 remember that's the softer pectin
what we respect to be more fluid and
what we can see is that in the 3 percent
sucrose case we're starting to get more
signal at these transverse walls than we
ever had before it's basically like an
empty column in the zero-percent and now
we're getting some on these transverse
walls so the ratio between the two is
getting closer to one so you're getting
more soft pectin on that wall that's now
elongating a bit more and giving you
that shift to width growth over length
so you get more methylated home electron
into the transverse walls and the
converse is also true with the
demethylated pectin although it's really
a little bit less obvious quantitatively
we can see this but the quantifications
again a grain of salt we're getting a
shift
away from those transverse walls so
you're getting less rigid packed in
there more soft pectin which might
relate to why you're getting that width
growth so you don't normally get so we
can see an interesting effect when we
look with the AFM I forgot to change the
title that literally makes no sense but
we can call it figure seven okay so if
you do the AFM again these are the basal
cells that are elongating what you'll
see is that these look more rigid than
the zero percent sucrose you can also
see they're a bit fatter than these
which makes sense given the measurements
I've shown you but it also looks like
we're getting rid of that ratio that
difference between transverse and axial
walls and so here's just some
quantification of that so this is the
zero percent case where you see that
difference and there's less of a
difference here and also everybody's
more rigid so here's the ratio of the
transverse to axial which normally
favors stiffer axial transverse walls
and here we've kind of gotten rid of
that well so this is kind of weird
though because now I'm showing you that
the cell walls are stiffer but we know
they're still growing volumetrically the
same so if my walls are stiffer how do I
still end up growing the same amount
even though it's proportioned a little
bit differently and so that was puzzling
to us and so we went in and asked well
is the pressure any different and so
we're estimating pressure here based on
plasmolysis point so it's not a perfect
method but it's what we have and what
you can see is that in three percent
sucrose the pressure is actually higher
in cells at the base when they're
growing so the walls may be stiffer but
they balance that out somehow by
regulating their pressure so that the
pressure - wall stiffness ratio is still
facilitating the same amount of growth
and that's something again there's an
interesting feedback there that we're
not sure how it's happening you can you
can get that kind of dynamic actually
out of a classical Lockhart model and
we're doing some modeling to look at
that but it's unclear what the actual
mechanism might be in this case so
maybe you're interested in oxen because
it's plants so and we know that change
is impacting can be affected by oxen so
we're looking a little bit at oxen
transporters and this is an example of
pin three so these are auxin efflux
carriers and so they can change the
direction of oxen flow depending on
their polarity and so in the
zero-percent sucrose case what we get is
something that's sort of not very polar
at all it's sort of around the whole
cell but maybe here you can see it's a
little bit stronger signal on the
transverse walls and we've done a bit of
quantification here so you have more
signal on transverse walls than you do
the axial elongating walls with sucrose
which means you end up with something
like this so you should have more pin3
on these membranes which will drive more
flow across those walls to get more oxen
flow across those transverse walls and
we think that's facilitating their
growth perhaps through acid growths and
this is impaired in up in three mutants
which is good it's always nice to have
mutants
so are there pH changes we might expect
that if there's more ox and flow across
that transverse wall that maybe we're
going to see a drop in pH if you believe
acid growth and so we've been using this
a profusion fluorescent protein system
and so what happens is you have our F P
which is pH insensitive and GFP which is
pH sensitive and you look at the ratio
between the two because they're both
produced by the same contract and they
go to the same April plastic space in
this case and you say what is the ratio
between green and red and that should
tell you something about the pH of the
system because this will get lower when
you have more acidic pH and so our rough
estimates again this is sort of
preliminary is that the pH ratio between
the transverse and axial walls sort of
is dropping in the 1.5 percent sucrose
and we sort of look at that as meaning
that we're getting lower pH on those
walls where more oxen is predicted to be
flowing across so we think there's some
acid growth change that's giving this
difference in width versus length and
this is impaired in proton pump mutants
but also if you add then kind of ice
which is an inhibitor of these proton
pumps okay so the summary of this part
goes like this we think that there's
this change in pectin octane polar
transport of auxin that changes the pH
we think that's doing something probably
2 p.m. YZ and PM e is on those
transverse walls we also have some hints
that xyla glucan structure is changing a
little bit on these walls as well and it
could be activating other enzymes like
expansions which we know are canonically
activated by changes in pH but then that
result is we think these transverse
walls in the sucrose condition are
growing a little bit faster than they
normally would which gives you this
slightly slower growing high picado it's
getting a little bit fatter but if you
remember I was kind of interested in
whether it mattered that you were a
little bit slower and a little bit
fatter does anybody care so we designed
some tests to look at this and again
we're just starting to do this and so
we're looking at success of emergence
because you could imagine just being
faster again it's awesome because you
get out and you start photosynthesizing
and you were the winner but if you have
different substrates that might not be
true and these are not the best
substrates but it's what we had at the
time so we're using coarse sand and fine
sand so you have different particle
sizes that you have to navigate through
but the thickness of the layer on top of
the seeds on the plate is the same and
we orient the seeds so they're already
ready to go up they don't have to do any
weird turning and this is the sort of
thing that we see so when you have
coarse sands the skinny fast one
actually does a little bit better but
when you have fine sand the fats low one
does a little bit better so the idea
would be that it's not always
advantageous to be fast it's not always
advantageous to be slow but somehow if
you can sense you know sensing your
environment and the carbon availability
allows you to change this and isotropy
and you may be a little bit more
successful than your friends but it's
obviously pretty complicated matrix of
interactions that we're just starting to
explore
so I'm very quickly gonna tell you a
little bit about pectin gel mechanics
cuz I've been kind of going through and
telling you oh well pectin gel is really
important and if it's stiffer that's
changes growth but we want to know a
little bit more about that as a material
so what does that actually mean so how
do you translate from this to the actual
wall structure and the way we've been
doing this is by really pulling stuff
way out of the plant system and just
making some synthetic materials and
testing them so first I'll show you some
pure pectin gels and we've developed
another test with the AFM so you will
probably be familiar with creep tests so
these are classical tests that we're
done where you took like a section of
high picado usually and you clamp it at
one end and you throw a weight on the
other end and you just measure the
deformation over time so instead of
these really fast elastic responses that
I've been talking about all along what
we wanted to do is actually look at the
way that the material flowed because
maybe that's a little bit closer to
growth than an elastic band so a good
viscoelastic material to think about
which is essentially what we're testing
here as a memory foam mattress which I
got to sleep on last night Thank You
Adrian so when you get in it you sink a
little bit over time so there's some
time dependence in your deformation and
when you get off at least when I get off
it takes a while to come back up but it
does come back up so there's this time
delay that might be a little bit more
realistically related to growth and so
the classical creep experiment involves
a weight on a whole organ and we've
simply miniaturized that using the AFM
so we push and hold a force and ask how
the material relaxes away from that so
that's stress relaxation you can push
and hold the deformation there's a
couple different ways to do it but
essentially you're asking about that
time deformation that happens and then
we take the data that we get and we put
it through a couple of different really
basic material models but this one works
pretty well it's what we call a standard
linear solid you have elasticity from
these Springs and you have the viscous
flow from these dashpots like a plunger
and a syringe and you can get parameters
for these different
out of your bottoms so when we do this
in pectin gels what do we see so what we
have here are pectin gels that have
different amounts of methylation so this
is 33% methylated so a lot of that is
available to calcium cross-linked and
what we can see is that instantaneous
stiffness which is analogous to the
indentation modulus earlier is high so
the less methylation you have the more
pectin calcium cross-links you can make
the stiffer you come that is good that's
what we would predict it's also what's
been predicted from food science
rheology for a long time this is not new
but what we have done is taken gels that
have different percentages of
methylation so for example here half of
it is methylated and you can see it's a
lot softer and something in between it's
not a linear relationship we've taken it
another step further and we've remade an
average 41% demethylation by missing 33
and 50 and we can see that it's not
quite the same as when the average is
actually 41 so you could imagine in a
cell wall it's not just that every
single hem electron and chain has
exactly 50% methylation but you might
have some that have 70 and some that
have 30 and what we find is that those
synergistic combination of those things
change the material properties as well
but what about the viscoelasticity
so what we can pull out of this is
something called relaxation time and i
think what i'm going to show you is is
not the relaxation time but i will tell
you that what happens is that the gels
are less stiff the more methylation you
have but they're also less viscous so
they're less thick they flow better and
if it makes sense that growth you might
want your material to be more elastic
but also have a bit more flow in it and
so the way that we look at this the
easiest way to look at this from the
models is actually to look at the ratio
of elasticity to viscosity and so
because the elasticity changes in order
for that ratio to remain constant you
have to have the viscosity changing in
the opposite manner and so we end up
knowing that as you're pectin
methylation goes down so you have more
available for cross links you get
stiffer and you flow less
can we see that in a plant so we go back
to this case where we have more rigid
transverse walls and more elastic axial
walls and we do these viscoelastic creep
tests there too and what we can see is
that we do see a difference in
elasticity from our model but also in
flow so pectin chemistry doesn't just
affect elasticity it's also affecting
the ability of the material to flow
which may be more related to growth but
we'll see we still have to show that
that is actually true okay the last
thing we don't have very much data on
yet is we're starting to build more
complex materials and so to do this we
use cellulose from this bacterial glue
can acetobacter zile Ennis that makes
cellulose outside its body we take that
cellulose and add in other cell wall
components so that the architecture
isn't going to be the same exactly as a
cell wall but hopefully we can get some
information from it and then we just
test these big hunks of material for
their material properties and we can
control them a bit better than we can
say in a mutant in a rabbit offsets so
here's a very brief example of some of
the things that change if you have
cellulose cellulose was pectin cellulose
enzyme glue can you get differences in
the weight so the hydration which makes
sense pectins a little bit wetter can
hold more water you get changes in the
depths of the material
so actually xyla glue can looks like
it's really linking things more tightly
so proportionally of the same amount of
cellulose and all these gels it's just
that you're getting a thinner material
because the xyla glue can and we have
some difference in young's modulus as
well but we're just starting to explore
this and what we're hoping is by Chris
Eisley controlling the components in the
wall we might get a better idea of
what's actually happening in a plant so
well my last slide going very long is
that we're starting to be able to do AFM
based mechanical measures on sections so
if you remember everything I've showed
you is from the epidermis but all those
tissue layers are connected to each
other and so you might want to know
something about internal cells and their
mechanics and so what I'm showing you
right now is the Miscanthus stem cryo
sections they haven't gone through any
fixation at all or in bedding except in
OCT media and right now we're just
looking at vascular bundles because
those are
obviously going to be really
mechanically different it's a good place
to start but we're hoping to be able to
look at primary cell walls as well that
don't have these really rigid polymers
to but so you can see here the phloem is
softer than the sieve elements which are
softer than the xylem that makes a lot
of sense and we can see some interesting
differences between sieve elements and
companion cells here within the phloem
as well and so this um we can relate
this to some interesting Galacta
epitopes as well through work with Paul
Knox and that'll be coming out in plant
fizz
but it just shows you that if you keep
pushing the method hopefully we can
start asking even more questions and not
just relying only on the epidermis so
hopefully you'll do that when you do
okay
most of this pretty much all of this
work that I've talked about today was
done at the lab in Cambridge but as it
removed as Adrienne mentioned we're now
at UCLA so we're continuing the work
these are the people who did it um two
postdocs for us to do here and Tom
Toyota and two PhD students JJ 10 and
Louie Kaplan so material scientist and
mathematician while biochemists and cell
biologists it's a really
interdisciplinary effort and that's our
money thanks very much so the questions
about the atomic force measurements and
whether we're doing in a constant
deformation it's really difficult to do
that with the way the machines work so
you actually have to do with a constant
force so there so when we do the creep
tests we are choosing forces that give
us the same deformation yes so in the
plants what we tend to do and again this
is really hand wavy we tend to say well
we want an indentation depth that's no
more than 5% of the depth of say the
wall because we want to make sure we're
so in an elastic regime but it's really
hand wavy
because most of the rules that have been
used to model and determine these
parameters from these experiments are
with solid materials and plant cell
walls are cellular solids and so there's
some complicated geometry that goes into
it so generally we try and get you know
either 5% of the depth of the wall or 5%
of the depth of the cell depending on
the type of experiment but one of the
things we're doing now is sticking an
AFM and appealed epidermal layer on top
of an inverted confocal and actually
looking at what the deformation if this
out looks like under AFM and it's not as
beautiful and straightforward as a
Hertzian model would want you to yeah so
for the gels we've done this a little
bit more carefully so because the def
for me because it's a finite it's a
continuous media and so you can look at
if you increase your indentation depth
or force you can look at the linearity
of their response and things like this
and the gels look pretty good I'm a
little bit worried about doing those
kinds of experiments right now in plants
just because what we think is happening
is at one point you'll deform a wall
then you'll be deforming the whole wall
then you'll be deforming those walls and
the cross walls and maybe the tissue
underneath it and so it's not as
straightforward as you would expect
based on simple material mechanics
because you have that cellular
architecture but we can talk about a bit
after - how does the high picado know to
go up so please correct me if I'm wrong
I believe it has to do with state'll
it's in the endodermis in the high
picado so there's gravity sensing starch
containing granules that change probably
oxen transport yeah and then keep it
growing up one that follows what Brandis
question was getting at it that is I
notice
that you had hot spots where the three
anticlinal walls come together so that
makes perfect sense because you got more
solid material in that location and you
have a poison effect kind of a
mechanical constraint yeah okay so the
question there is how do you compensate
for that extent and the other not
question but observation it's that you
show that when you have more fine sand
hmm the sucrose which causes an
expansion they're more successful
actually that makes sense because if you
look at the circumferential expansion it
propagates a fracture okay so it's
better at pushing through those grains
which are more densely packed in the
fine grain thank you that's a very
that's very helpful I can go back to the
first point which is and especially this
has to do when you're doing sections as
well an AFM on section so you get these
sort of nice try Junction middle lamella
areas where what everybody does right
now and whether or not that's a good
thing to do is they assume that you have
an incompressible material and so all
these equations you're using a Poisson
ratio of 0.5 so you make a lot of
assumptions I think that and
indefinitely so the the wall that
because that geometry becomes important
as well as you said because you have a
thicker amount of material it may appear
stiffer because it has less room to move
in we haven't started doing that yet but
you could there's a lot of simulations
you can do simulated indentations and
finite element models which could be a
way for controlling for that yeah I
think that's probably what we'll do so
we'll just make a section and indent on
it in in silico yeah this is one more
question that I was interested I assumed
and that when you're talking about
detectives you're talking about
detectives within this so question is
what is happening in the
or belly and the Galactic erotic assets
that are binding themselves together
particularly where you have those three
junctions so yeah I can repeat the
question so it's it's asking so I'm
making some conclusions about pectin in
the cell wall but I'm not making
distinctions between we're in the cell
while we're looking so the middle
lamella which is responsible for the
adhesion of cells together is that
different than say the the proximal
primary cell wall to the cell which may
be more growth regulatory so our
measurements right now haven't been fine
enough to really tell us the difference
between metal lamella and proximal like
right next to the to the cell my postdoc
for us is really interested in looking
at cell adhesion and its maintenance and
so he started looking at some actin
mutants that we can see have mechanical
differences but I'm hoping that this
section technique really fine tips
really fine scans might actually let us
see differences in middle lamella versus
primary cell wall I think that's
probably the best way to go in the
galactica that's coming out and plant
phys we can see that there's in a single
wall in a sieve element there's a
gradient of binding of the antibody for
Galacta and there's a gradient of
mechanics across the wall so we're
starting to be able to see that kind of
resolution but we don't really have the
answers so the question is whether we've
seen any change in plasmid is not a
number size maybe even opening with
changes in pectin methylation and we
haven't looked so that is a bad answer
for you but it is the answer so we
haven't looked one might expect that the
more rigid the gel gets maybe the less
easy it is for plasma does not at a
dilate I know that there are people
looking at the kalos deposition and
we've been doing some measurements for
them and what calestous the material
properties of the wall and because kalos
accumulation may be you know more better
than I do
callus accumulation around plasmodesmata
can really restrict also
their dilation but it's a question that
sometimes we get asked and I don't have
a really good answer for it I mean I
think the only way to look would be to
ask whether some plastic movement is
different when you have the PME
induction versus the PMI pai but we
haven't done this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu